we got to start it over
hit it mike
[Music]
um
[Music]
that's the way to get the morning
started baby
it is now in fact hot in here
and i have just pulled something
hello ray lewis my friend
oh my friend
of the smoke
you know what it's so funny because i
told this story by the way ray lewis is
here uh beyond the edge premiering
tonight 9 eastern on cbs a new reality
series in which he is competing and
we'll talk about that on this show there
it is there you are right in the middle
of the panama
jungle metal world peace and mike
singletary some of the sports
names and faces we recognize right there
it's funny i was telling this story the
other day about
oh boy well about the pro bowl
uh oh man
oh man where are you
and rob woodson were part of nfl total
access at the pro bowl this is this is
the this is the super bowl season where
betis
won and strolled off into the sunset of
his career which you know you eventually
got to chance to do yourself
and um beating seattle and detroit
and you and rod and i are on the set of
nfl total access at the end of at the
end of a show he's laughing already
so
where where
you taught me how to hit
right now
i got a tackle properly right absolutely
and you were telling me you know like
get you know
bend down absolutely you know get down
explode
up yes right get down yes you know not
bend over at the hip switch back right
down
remember i remember doing it right and
then you go in your chest hit with your
chest one thousand see what you hear see
what you hit through with your
absolutely and then i did that
and rod was holding the bag yep you let
go of it
and i went through it
and you're laughing
and rod's laughing
and um when you when you hit the ground
it was the most classic thing i've ever
seen in my life
and the crazy thing is it was like two
hours later because it was what a setup
it was because we were staying at the
pro bowl hotel yeah
and we're at the beach
and i'm just like trying to get up from
the sand and and i can't move my arm
i sprained my ac joint
and to this day to this day rod says he
did not let go of the bag yeah yeah
i don't know if you have any memory of
this but can you break the tie here
because i swear i do have a memory of
this rich i don't know if i want to
expose it
i just don't know if that's the right
thing to do you know cause somebody i
got to put somebody by the bus that's
right me or rod and this was me
but you guys are my two friends i don't
know who i could throw on the bus oh my
gosh
well you you wanted to i was supposed to
hold the bag that's all i'm gonna say
okay he was supposed to hold the back
man so as you can see ray you and i uh
we go way back yeah way back in the day
so uh we're in the free agency period
right now did you ever get close to that
never never uh ravens never let you get
close no it was um
i think my one of my last deals
and uh steve called me and he was like
take seven days
call me when you're ready
and we just laughed about this
i just sat with him the other day it was
just shotty yeah the only time under the
ravens yeah he says uh
he says hey
i heard you a free agent take seven days
let me know when you're done i said i
don't actually
go on a tour to go i just said i'll call
you back when i get from vacation
and i went on vacation
and uh but i had like two three offers
forget who it was you know offering this
crazy money and i'm like hmm
so you want me to take
10 plus million and leave my legacy
can't do it
so you left that on the table yeah man
absolutely it was no it was not even
i never second guessed it you know like
two of my favorite all-time athletes
and this is
this is before this new day and age
right where there's no loyalty no more
sports right it's who did you bet on
this week that's who win it right but
when i was a kid michael jordan
and joe montana to me
was like
never supposed to take off a bull in the
san francisco uniform right ever
and when that happened
years before i even got in the lead rich
i knew that wherever i was going
i'm never leaving that was the one thing
i always had in my head
go to one city and never leave that city
now i didn't know that city wasn't going
to have a name right when i got drafted
right
that's amazing
h called me 26 people that would drive
to you
who's drafting me
who
we don't you don't have a team there's
no team in baltimore what okay got it
i'm drafted to
yeah i guess baltimore yeah yeah so yeah
man i never even thought about leaving
uh when it came came to a free agency
and that's one of the blessings of my
career because i
you know i signed four deals um there
and
yeah it was like they know what i was
about we i knew what they were about and
it never came down to any money issues
or
me bitter with anybody and to leave the
legacy that i love
being in one city for 17 years
you know you can go around the entire
globe for the rest of your life it's
rare that you're going to have somebody
that stays home
and home for me was bigger than the game
the game was just
the thing right the platform
but
but the community that i invested in and
still invested into the to this day
right i wanted that to be forever so
are you
really not remembering it or you're just
being
you know on time that you don't remember
which teams were trying to give you 10
million dollars more yeah
yeah it's irrelevant right because i
would disagree with the relevance of it
it's irrelevant now why yes yes
and you did win another super bowl yeah
your legacy yeah but i just like who
who's knocking on your door right who's
knocking on your door nice come on years
ago cowboy's knocking on you you know
you know some of the time
when you got that old phone and you know
you need to get rid of that old
dolphins like to come home dolphins did
the dolphins ask you to come back
to the other one who knows
everybody missed out let's just say that
you know dallas made a play rich i hated
it in baltimore
yes you did
and it's interesting that you say that
that that that's worth it because now
rogers has that opportunity
you know aaron rodgers has that
opportunity but brady
doesn't it's one of the few things that
brady will not have the opportunity to
say that he's in one place but he did
win another one yeah what did you make
ray lewis here on the rich eisenstein
what did you make of tom's decision to
un-retire even though when he retired he
never used the word retire right yeah
just you knowing what it's like to leave
this game that you put so much into yeah
what did you make of tom you know i
think the competitive side of thomas
is the easy noticeable thing right right
he's one of the greatest competitors
ever and
the one thing i said when i got ready to
retire if you've got more in the tank
finish it empty the tank right i don't
think he's finished i don't think the
tank is empty for his passion for i'm
done now i think if they would have won
it i think he walks out right but
tasting glory
and then losing the way they did last
year
and living with that the rest of your
life
i don't know if that's his pedigree so i
you know i think if you listen to his
his entire world of i'm retiring but
kind of it's kind of open
i don't know i just i think his passion
for the game still burns
and i say to anybody
if you got it ride it
ride it and
whenever you ready to let go me for me
it was kind of an easy decision because
i said
this is my last ride right i didn't go
after the season was over you said it
going in going in right did you do that
to to maybe even
block off
what you might have i i actually didn't
come through if you i caught
that no i called steve
and i called my daughter
and i said dime i said daddy has to make
a really tough decision i said
i just tore my tricep from the bone like
they say i can never come back but i'm
coming back
so when i come back i'm coming back to
do one thing
one more one more dance and she was like
dad don't come back during the season
you know steve was like
you know paula willis reed
come back in the place
yeah i love steve and uh so yeah so
bottom line i think for me i did it my
way
and
it ended
on the four-yard line
in new orleans
no greater way a defensive player would
ever want to go out so for brady
it's like
how do you want how do you want it to
end right we know what it's been
how do you want to see the end jb your
own bet is
champion forever the last time you ever
saw him play the last time i've ever
scrapped up my cleats
triceps on the knot right
i held the lombardi trophy i think
that's that's a crave that's a crave for
brady after you've seen it seven times
you know that's something that says wow
if i can walk out one more time like
this now i don't know if he's chasing a
dream that may not happen
right i think it's a lot of people have
gotten better
definitely in the nfc is going to make
it tough think about what you just said
seven times seven times that's
it's crazy and and just showing you
again
ray that he
wants to do the eighth time that it
means just as much to him maybe as the
other seven
i i i it's a rarity to have that ticking
clock within your system yeah i would
think yeah you know yes they're it's
definitely rare
did you what was your biggest battle
against brady you had so many of them
yeah what was it like going against
brady in the playoff game right yeah it
was probably
for me and him
i think we had so much respect for each
other
um
because he understood the chess match
and the chess match was i know what
you're running
and what i'm telling you is you may
deliver the ball but somebody's going to
pay for that
right
and so
you know he you know he gave he said
this thing on his interview a few weeks
a few months back right that when he
actually competed against me he knew
that i knew
so he had to be careful where the ball
was going
you know me and julian edelman now like
we work together now right
[Music]
but julian understood
wherever that's a punishment back when
we was playing ball right that's a
punishment to catch the ball so it was
chess
i knew where you're going hollow back
side two by two back offset you come
back and throw you motion to the three
side to see a win man we come back we
shift out of man go back to two and then
on one on one with your running back
every time so that was the chess match
how can you get me to move three steps
to the right or three steps to the left
or get ed to see something different and
i'm like ed don't move
trust me he's right and so that chess
match between me him it was
it was probably one of the most classic
things ever
never noticed
because it was in the small changes that
you had to know what we both were doing
yeah
it was
it's one of the greatest battles
that i used to stay up really late for
and
look at film enough to say
somebody going to get knocked out
because i know he going through it
and and so that was my thing my thing
was he will throw it
but there's a delivery that comes with
that and that's what i think what made
us so competitive against each other is
we knew like he we knew how good they
were
right we knew
outside of us and pittsburgh and them
like the road was going to come through
right those areas in that region and um
2011 for me
i think when we went to new england and
we lost that one
i wouldn't i would never say i wanted it
you know
more
i would just say
i thought we were better equipped
to do what we needed to do
if we would have finished that
right so when you
were going in these battles with brady
do you ever verbalize it pre-snap every
play
i'm not playing with brady
but he he know though but that's the
thing like julian like that's what we
talk about when brady he comes to the
line i'm saying i'm telling you what
you're running that's what you would run
you'd say that i'm telling you where
it's coming yeah it's like that's that
was my my secret sauce was
i
i stayed up
i stayed up and played the game
after 2000 after 1998 man peyton manning
was first at the pro bowls
old school pro bowls
and i never and i never understand i
never understood
peyton's wife's so cool she's oh my god
she's amazing
and she's like he studies you all day
every day and i'm like really
i don't
so i need to change my game
so i started studying him more though
right you know quarterbacks all they do
is click so i built an entire room in my
house
just so i can watch film so i became
this guy that wanted to know everything
when i went to marvin lewis and said i
want to know every check
that a defense run
that we run that we have why do we check
out why do we stay in a certain defense
on first down to 10 or second right
so all of those little things when you
think about the game now yeah
that's what you see missing from the
defensive side of the game right the
defensive side of the game now is
look react
out mine was
look
destroy
or either intercept it or knock it down
not catch it in the enemy because you've
done the the work to know what's coming
or what their tendency is back in rich
rich that back in when you actually get
to
plan
those type of chess match games against
brady and payton
it's the smallest things ever that will
decide the wins and losses in that game
it's not this big touchdown or this but
no it's the smallest things it's me
knowing peyton come to peyton come to
the line second down and eight and i see
that the receiver right leg is up on the
line instead of his left leg is up on
the line and the outside receive his
back yard then i know i'm getting that
high low right now
so i know two driving up and number one
coming in and no the corner can't make
that play yeah because the corner has to
sit off
so the only person that can affect that
play if you know it's coming
is the middle back
and that's the difference of when i
watch football
i'm like screaming at kids like
you gotta know the game if you can count
to one two three as a middle linebacker
you can you can be a very effective
person
so are you talking to anybody in the
game today to say you talk to a lot of
people i know you do yeah or you so who
are you
who do you think is equipped to do this
or is is doing something i think i think
rich honestly
we have to because the game has changed
right the game is now about the
the
the guy that get that can get to the
quarterback
and the quarterback
yeah that's the game that seems to be
the game that's the game it's certainly
that's when you play the super bowl
so that's where your defensive players
years are coming from because the only
thing that's
now kind of relevant is the d lineman
and you know the quarterback but
the essence of a middle linebacker
is the
general on that side of the ball
everything there's no way you can walk
to a line and i want you to really just
watch the game
you walk to the you watch the game now
and you the last thing you see is
communication
in my defense it's the first thing you
must everybody's communicating you got
to know what's coming right if i if i
see knuckles in the ground i'm screaming
rabbit
if i see knuckle if i see fingers
extended i'm screaming bird rabbit is
run bird is passed
right but i'm giving my d-line
some sort of a clue on either to be
heavy or be light
right so now you play the game different
right i'm looking at my corners i'm
saying look damn bunch something coming
right it's the little things and so
um
that's the thing that i try to when i
talk to people or try to explain to any
of my camps i try to explain our
greatness wasn't me our greatness was i
was able to communicate
what made us great
right it's like pulling your shoestring
i always use this analogy if you pull
your shoe straight too far one way the
other side going to be short it's the
same thing in defense defense has to be
on one string
when the ball moves even if you're wrong
as a complete defense
if everybody's doing the same thing
you're right
and if you're going full speed who cares
ray lewis here on the rich eisen show i
love this stuff we've got another
segment let's take a break we'll come
back for the peacock and siriusxm
audience we're going to show you a clip
of beyond the edge that premieres
tonight 9 eastern on cbs you're in the
jungle of panama correct competition i
still don't know how i got there
[Laughter]
let me make that clear
i still don't know the production looks
beautiful okay
okay okay see that look cute that ain't
cute
that isn't cute y'all can see what y'all
want to say i'm he'll have a nightmare
about quicksand
it it was a it was an amazing thing to
do once you got there
but that wasn't cute i'm serious like
that hurt i got scars from that get out
of here i'm
rich i got scars
wounds
battle
it's like i was back on the field
i i just
you know when when the guys when we
talked when we first had the
conversation i
i just did not understand i was going to
live in the jungle for 15 days
i thought maybe you filmed from a hotel
you know shout out you know
look you get up in the morning they pick
you up at 5 30. they have your back at 9
30. i could sleep in my bed and shout
out crap services you thought these
scratches since i get out there and we
sleeping with monkeys
rich we with snakes black scorpions
i'm one of them one of the nights i
ain't gonna tell you the show but one of
the nice i'm telling i'm sleeping right
and you know we got to sleep with a net
over us because we actually outside on
bamboo stick
so it's storming every night
and i promise you i
i shouldn't tell this well
it it it is you'll see them well i'll
just say
ray lew is here on the rich island show
telling a story of uh recording beyond
the edge tonight cbs at nine eastern
time so you're you're out where you're
out in the yeah
in japan
okay in the middle
dropped off rich
on a bus
can't see nothing
don't know where you're going don't know
how to get back home
and they drop us off
and they say this is where you're going
to live for the next 15 days
and i'm standing in the middle and
everybody's looking at me and i'm like
i'm not staying here
i can't why they already look at you
because you're the automatically the
leader like i mean right do something
somebody say something right right and
and and and
you know of course we're doing this to
benefit our charities right and i'm like
man how much can i write a check for i
can just write a check to the charity
oh god i ain't been i have not it's i'm
telling you this seriously i have not
been the same since
since i came back from that jungle
the point is we get dropped off
everybody has a charity
that they're supporting mine was john
hopkins children's hospital i've been
working with them for many years um and
to see these kids and to know the impact
so every day that you stayed you made
more money but there was these tests
there was these mental tests there was
these physical tests that you had to do
daily
so by the third day what really happened
is god had to be introduced
because you don't have food
you don't have water you have to find it
and you're sleeping wow on bamboo sticks
where it storms every night and i'm
saying to myself right i'm like
okay this is a show so somebody got to
come get us
there's no way they can leave us in the
thunderstorm
nobody came to get us
so we get up the next morning and we're
like man this is
so me and um
me and coach um mike cenatary
we was
roommates whatever you want if you want
to call it roommates because there's no
room there's no room
it's just mates it's a piece of wood
and huge is laying up you land on it so
so then you know before i even decided
this i had this whole conversation with
my team and everybody and it was just
like no it'd be great it'll be amazing
and i was like yeah
it will be
and i got there we went through it and i
think the bonding
that happened from it
is kind of a metaphor for what
our world
should adopt which is
truly loving our neighbor
as thyself regardless of where you come
from regardless of your race
we all had to figure out
how to work together and and what made
it really tricky
is you couldn't get
comfortable with someone because every
day you had a different teammate
some days you may end up the same but
every day there's a different captain
there's a different order so now you
have to communicate differently so
that's the way this show works yeah and
so who winds up becoming the the
champion like how did this how did so
the champion see and so that's what
makes this really good because
of course there's a winner but there is
no winner
there's everybody wins right as long as
you go but at the end of course whoever
raised the most money i see yeah really
comes home with the prize but there's no
prize right the prize is
if you can if you can cut this out right
there will be people that will benefit
from
your sacrifice and so hundreds of
thousands of dollars
um was raised um because the crew
did one heck of a job and honestly this
cast
craig
morgan
one of became one of my favorite people
in the whole world
he is he is the i'm telling you we talk
so much we face time so much
just to hear each other's laugh
right because we trusted him him being a
military man
and some of these circumstances rich
where you had to find your own water
right like really dig for water like wow
right and
then we
started to travel and to see that these
circumstances was like this for real for
a lot of people
right and we were doing it for
you know of course to benefit people
the hardest thing i've probably ever
done
um in my entire life wow i'm because
it's the unknown sure of course and
you're surviving in the jungle of panama
yeah what was it like with the
singletary no it was the greatest you he
was your coach right back in the day he
was your position coach back in the day
he's your but don't go that fast because
1985 i was 10 years old
and he was the person that i admired to
be like
you're sitting there
dreaming of becoming michael
mike singletary as he's doing his what
does 85 mean
when i couldn't play football
i was like wow that's he's that intense
what is it that he knows that i don't
know
so as a kid i started following him
and then him and lawrence taylor was
kind of my two ronnie lott was the other
one sure i have a lot of people i was by
the way you chose well yeah
[Laughter]
i had a lot of guys that i just actually
love but
i think just like craig
i think me and coach
we had conversations that we had never
had before
as men
we shared vulnerabilities
that
in the locker room you don't
you do
and the day that i
i had this
crazy blurred out and lost my mind
playing against the jets because i knew
the call
and defensive coordinator called another
call and i lost my mind because i knew
they was gonna run the ball whatever and
he called me to the sideline and he was
like you can't speak to
no your voice carries way farther than
anybody else
and it's caught on camera and i'm like
what the [ __ ] yeah i think that was on
nfl films you caught that was that mike
nolan too
i remember this right i remember
he gets i think he got in like you got
on the phone no because there he was
called under michael's like get on ray
right and i'm like coach i hear you
right but you got to think like this me
ryan i'm trying to humble myself to look
at this lion in his eyes and saying
coach i'm listening i remember this
right so i'm like okay i'm here i'm
listening tell me what you want to tell
me right your voice can't care like that
he forever changed the course of me as a
leader
right because from that moment my voice
never raised as a leader if it was not
passion
right
we get in the jungle
and we're roommates
and there's no real sleep you're not
looking to get five six hours at least
okay right you're not prepping to go to
go to bed
like you're just laying down hopefully
you can stay asleep right and we ended
up sitting up
and i'm telling you the intimacy of
what we found out as men
why we connected
because we all
we me and him in particular
we experienced some
really rough things to try to come out
of
you know and so we started to share that
and so that's why i said like it turned
into this like
it's always like the spiritual retreat
right because
i started like going on like i wasn't
even thinking about food i was like you
know what i'm done we're not gonna eat
we're trying to fish we're putting rod
we're putting strings in the water
nothing is happening
but me and mike man we fell in love with
each other all over again i think we did
and uh
the whole crew there though
the whole crew richard was the toughest
thing
that i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you as a
friend don't ever do
i want to make sure we're clear
because i think we're correct
i appreciate that right back at you
seriously guys i created an app yes that
blocks all reality shows from getting in
touch with
me eastern
how'd he do
how'd he do i'm not uh
it's just like me getting up this
morning right
and i said
i got to get up this morning and i got
to drive in la traffic
where i'm going i must be in love with
the person that got me there is that me
i appreciate it the traffic's not that
bad
not bad this morning okay first time in
l.a traffic wasn't right ray lewis
i know it's not your first time in l.a
because you ran for st jude last year
yeah and you won it yeah took it down
you and mark glory took it down you know
then now he owns the timberwolves now
you're on you're on uh beyond the edge
that's a lot of things happen when you
win the run rich run
i'd have and you run to 40.
um ray lewis here on the rich eisen show
before i let you go uh and by the way
check on the traffic to make sure ray's
going to get back
can you get something you raise it for
him where is it for him yeah okay um
so what do you think uh is uh with
lamar's long-term future in baltimore
what do you think ray because you know
it seems like eric decosta and the
ravens would love to sit here and talk
long-term contract with him and yeah
either he's not ready or he's
representing himself or he's just
a different
type of
you know
nfl player who's not concerned about his
long-term future it'll all just come to
him he just wants to win right now is
what it seems like what do you think
yeah i think um
honestly
i um
he's one of the young kids that i
that i purposely pray for a lot
because
for him to understand
the mantle
that he now carries in baltimore
you know
i think it's way bigger than football
i think
um i think he's clear
on
what he wants to do
right
and sometimes you know you can't
fault a person for doing what the way
that they see it um
but i think when it comes down to the
contract in the rabies i think a deal
will get done okay um
i really do
and
yeah i think it gets done and we keep
taking our city to the next level and he
keeps knowing what he's doing well it's
interesting you say his mantle in
baltimore do you think if there is a
torch
that it's been passed from you to him
he has to it's no if you know it's like
he has to
and i've been gone from the game 10
years
right like i get it like
that's whatever my city i get it right
but
the new sheriff
that he carries a different master he
has to understand that and i think he
does
i really do i think he
i don't think he understands sometimes
the magnitude
of where he could reach and how far he
can go
and none of us at 24 25 years old had
everything figured out what if somebody
had come up to you when you were 24 25
said that to you yeah
yeah you know so i mean would you have
understood i mean i think i think
um the same thing i told lj
lamar is
i had somebody
to help me walk through
whatever greatness you're running into
you're not doing nothing no different
nobody else did so you got to have the
right counsel
right and so for me
the guy we spoke about earlier rob
wilson
rod
basically just took me
he said i understand that you
you're great you can do a lot
but you need me to help you
right and that's what i think um
lamar
he's you got to have the right counsel
in these type of decisions because they
affect not just him
i think he needs to understand that
clearly like this is this affects an
entire culture
a raven nation of of what young kids
who was told they couldn't play a
position right go play receiver lamar
now i'm a quarterback
yeah that was
no question right something that he
needed to do unfortunately at the
combine like i'm not running receiver
routes here like get out of here with
that and i'm not running a 40 here
because i'm not gonna have the
conversation from here be how fast i am
and like he
amazing and then obviously ozzie newsome
with the ultimate you know uh
you know gift basket as he's going out
the door yeah great
move to go get him there's an extra year
of contractual control if you want to
talk about the business a little bit
here and so now clearly he is
uh
supremely talented no question about
that what about though and just bringing
this all full circle we had such a
terrific conversation in the first
segment of you here about
how
it's now down to past rushers and
quarterbacks yeah and he clearly can get
away from past rushes but at some point
it might be somebody like you coming
downhill and taking him out and how
sustainable do you think his level of
play is in the nfl right man you think
and we know this game now so
uh any play
is that play yep you know
practice
you know i hurt myself in practice right
it's it's that's
i think that's the last thing any of us
think about right right now when you
start to get into the contractual stuff
of course they're going to talk about it
but it's really irrelevant in your in
your mindset right and in his world that
he should live in injury is the last
thing the one things about lamar is a
football player
and he's going to give you everything he
got and when you think about the core of
what a football player is
what the hall of famers ultimately
live their entire life being that's the
person that gives everything empty's the
tank
that's who he is
and
injury who cares
right i had nine surgeries who cares
keep going and you'll figure it out so
look
you of course you hear all of the
oh if he gets hurt
one hit one hit yeah
it's for a lot of people right but that
kid is special he has the it factor
and people
love to play with him and for him and
for me
he's one of those people that i run home
because i know something's magical is
gonna happen right right and i just
think he has to keep that in his forward
of thinking with the right counsel and i
think he'll be okay
right you're the man thanks for coming
here no man thank you buddy so good to
see you man it's very good to see you
yeah what's your time this year in the
40 um you know i got to start training
and
uh we're going to so you haven't started
this room
uh this is just a question there is no
there
there there is no re system you know
what i mean like so you're just talking
to strengths i'm just asking yes
uh it's we're right now the tentative
plan that's becoming very firm and
finalized is five weeks from
saturday
oh the saturday before the draft
is where we're gonna is when we're gonna
run it i can't really announce just yet
where it's gonna be but it's gonna be
here in los angeles california you are
very much invited to return and and
defend your crown ray olympians
olympians start four years just to get
to the next olympics yes
you got five weeks and you ain't started
training yet well i mean i'm doing
mental reps
[Laughter]
so i'm doing i'm doing my mental wraps
right now okay
so yeah that's the way i approach it
let me see let me see the way i feel if
i could come back and defend it well i
mean just again to bring it all full
circle how limber did i look doing the
squirrel dance to start this
entire a appearance the dragon of the
leg is the most impressive thing to me
because that means you take your time
taking my time see that's that's one
thing people don't know about that then
it's a state of mind
look at my face that means i'm in awe
[Laughter]
that's where you were looking at me last
year i could not believe you did that
and you know people was recording that
but that's why i love you rick right
back at you ray let me see
thank you ray lewis on twitter and
instagram beyond the edge check it out i
mean if you you just heard how
real this thing is and this thing is a
celebrity adventure challenge in the
panama jungle with ray and meta world
peace
and uh mike singletary paulina porsakova
and more celebrities tonight on cbs
wednesdays at nine eastern time good to
see you ray hey buddy you got it hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here